every tech company wants to sell you a
wearable usually it's a watch or a
bracelet or a pair of glasses or who
knows what else but what if that
wearable could be something you're
already wearing like this shirt
that's the idea behind project jacquard
which comes out of Google's top-secret 8
app division and is designed to put
technology into the things you already
put on everyday persons that jacquard is
about weaving interactive surfaces using
industrial processes existing today with
the textile and yarn industry conductive
textiles aren't new or even all that
hard to make googles challenge is to
make these fabrics at scale and if it
can we might all be wearing smart shirts
in the future we can take any piece of
textile soon will any design and then
weave interactive areas into their
textiles Google's first partner for
project jacquard is Levi's and they
don't have any concrete plans yet but
they do have these big ideas what if you
could talk to your phone with just a
single swipe on your arm what if instead
of being something on your wrist or an
add-on to your shoe your fitness tracker
could just be your shoe and what if all
that work totally invisible
one day arute I realized just by taking
the phone but placing the phone in my in
my jacket this jacket by definition
becomes a smart jacket is that they're
not connected so what they're trying to
do is just to build this connection so
your mobile communication and the
garments you read because one single
thing exactly what that one thing will
be appears to still be in development
still both companies say it's time to
think about a future where all our
clothes are connected and they both say
that future isn't so far away when we
when so much of our lives now exists in
a digital space as well as the physical
environment we're living in we are
deeply engaged with a digital
environment the blue jeans of the future
might be talking to the cloud
you